Whether in D.C., London, Adelaide or Madrid,
nearly all giant pandas in today’s zoos
are technically there on a 5 or 10-year loan
from China, and at a substantial price.
It hasn’t always been this way, though.
Beginning in the late 1950s and through the
early 1980s, the People’s Republic of China
used the gift of a giant panda as a means
of diplomacy; during those three decades,
they gave over 23 pandas to nine countries
including Great Britain, Japan, Spain, United
States and Mexico.
Most of these gifted pandas have perished
(in captivity, giant pandas have an approximate
30 year lifespan compared to about 20 years
in the wild), although at Mexico City’s
Chapultpec Zoo, two “grandfathered” pandas
who are offspring of former gifted parents,
Shaun Shuan and Xin Xin, remain.
However, other than these two, it is difficult
to find a giant panda that doesn’t belong
to China.
Why?
In the early 1980s, China changed its policy
and decided to make a little money off of
this one-of-kind creature that, up until recently,
was really difficult to breed in captivity.
Accordingly, today China charges around $500,000
to $1,000,000 per year for the loan of a giant
panda, with, at least in the case of the United
States rentals since 2011, a considerable
amount of that money required to go to giant
panda conservation efforts.
As for the offspring of rented pandas, according
to the terms of the loans, any cubs born to
rented-out giant pandas are China’s property
and must be returned to the country after
roughly two years; in addition, if a cub dies
while on loan and it is deemed to be because
of human error, a penalty in the hundreds
of thousands of dollars range may also be
assessed.
The Chinese government also requires a life
insurance policy be taken out on each panda
loaned out.
In the United States, the contracted life
insurance policy must be $1 million, set to
be paid to the Chinese government should the
panda die.
In addition, according to the current U.S.
contract, if the death is deemed to be from
improper care or otherwise caretaker error,
an additional $800,000 must be paid to China.
Beyond the cost of acquiring them, giant pandas
are also expensive for zoos to maintain, as
they require special housing and, of course,
enormous amounts of fresh bamboo – with
an adult eating up to 40 pounds of the fibrous
plant each day.
(Note: if the bamboo isn’t fresh enough,
the pandas simply won’t eat it, requiring
that it either be grown nearby or imported
regularly.)
For reference on the total costs here, in
the last two decades the San Diego Zoo claims,
after all associated costs have been tallied,
they’ve spent over $40 million on their
giant panda exhibit.
However, the president of Zoo Advisors, David
Walsh, notes that “Yes, they are expensive
to maintain and exhibit, but they are a tremendous
draw.
It does make economic sense, if you have the
right market.”
For example, in the year 2000, the first year
the Atlanta zoo had giant pandas, it broke
attendance records, and after its first cub,
Mei Lan, was born in 2007, it saw another
attendance surge
of 25%.